[Música]
esto que pocas veces termino lavando
holocausto advierte una enorme carga que creo e
quien sabe si Trivia Alissa lo esta hablando
No miro la narrativa del Caballero
La vida humana settevisa Jesolo que uno
tener la manifestación de la guerra
illomisano cuando es famoso
es imposible calificarlo de que es
el holocausto significa que las caravanas
cuando eh este show
estamos apostando y el error mas grande
que como timos un clima se encuentra con el
la humanidad, siempre y cuando se proporciona uno cuando es
último
aspoliticos importa quienes son
desconciertos uno se esta perdiendo es el
valor humano pero importante pregunté
pregunté mientras conducía
la guía humana
Amicis
quiere decir que ya estas en la cabeza que ya tienes
más allá del punto de exclamación